du Pax à la PMA 30 ans de combat pour
l'égalité des droits un documentaire
réalisé par Marie Guillou et qui vient
donc de nous remémorer le long chemin
parcouru pour parvenir à une égalité des
droits entre couples étos et homosexuel
avec pour conséquence vous l'avez vu une
profonde remise en cause du modèle de
filiation qui avait jusque-l prévalu
dans notre pays comment ces nouveaux
droits ont-ils rebattu les cartes au
sein de la cellule familiale et bien
nous allons en parler maintenant avec
nos invités présents aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau de débat dog tout d'abord
Patrick Bloche c'est la magie de la
télévision on vous a vu dans ce
documentaire à plusieurs époques
d'ailleurs hein et on vous retrouve donc
avec nous sur ce plateau merci de votre
présence vous êtes ancien député
socialiste aujourd'hui adjoint à la
mairie de Paris chargé de l'éducation de
la petite enfance et des nouveaux
apprentissages vous avez été on le
rappelle néanmoins même si ça a déjà été
dit le co-auteur et le rapporteur de la
proposition de loi sur le Pax voté en
1999 vous êtes l'auteur de l'incroyable
histoire du Pax 20 ans après le récit un
ouvrage co-écrit avec le regretté
Jean-Pierre Michel on l'a vu lui aussi
dans dans ce film tout comme un autre de
vos co-auteurs Denis quinqueton qui
était également dans dans ce film pour
témoigner de ce qui a été ce ce long
combat eu dont vous étiez en quelque
sorte hein à à l'origine merci encore
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui avec avec
Sarah l bienvenue à vous vous êtes
vice-présidente du MoDem ancienne
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
biodiversité au sein du dernier
gouvernement d'Élizabeth borne vous avez
été aussi la première femme membre d'un
gouvernement à avoir révélé votre
homosexualité vous êtes une toute jeune
maman avec votre compagne grâce grâce à
la PMA pour toute qui a été adoptée en
en 2021 et votre dernier livre
s'intitule lui envie de France publié
chez humens 6 vous nous ferez part de
votre témoignage de cet heureux
événement et et de la manière dont euh
vous préparez la suite avec votre
compagne et et ce nouvel enfant dans
votre famille irenne Terry enfin est
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes sociologue
spécialiste de la sociologie du droit de
la famille et de la vie privée et votre
dernier livre s'intitule lui moi aussi
la nouvelle civilité
sexuelle un ouvrage disponible aux
éditions du Seuil on va commencer après
ce film et ces 30 ans d'histoire ce long
combat euh avec ces quelques chiffres
regardez tout d'abord en 2023 le nombre
de mariages en France alors d'une part
les mariages de personnes de sexe
différents
235000 et puis les mariages de personnes
de même sexe qui se qui s'établissait à
à 7000 mariages en 10ant euh 70000
couples de même sexe se sont mariés euh
le le nombre de mariages de de personnes
de même sexe est de 7 % un un une
proportion qu'on va retrouver dans la
ligne d'après d'ailleurs concernant le
le Pax ce cette proportion de 7 % mais
cette fois on parle donc du Pax en 2022
199477 personnes de sexes différents
c'était paxés et
10350 personnes de même sexe c'était
paxé euh c'est d'ailleurs le niveau le
plus élevé depuis la création du Pax en
1999 quel succès ce Pax vous l'expliquez
comment je l'explique par la capacité
finalement de la société à intégré si
j'ose dire des des avancées des acquis
et ce qu'il y a de passionnant avec le
le Pax c'est que finalement une
revendication qui visait à reconnaître
les couples de même sexe a amené à la
création d' un cadre juridique nouveau
moderne le Pax avec des droits et des
devoirs et finalement ce sont les
couples hétérosexuels qui 20 ans 25 ans
plus tard Assur le succès statistique du
Pax et ce qu'il y a de frappant aussi
dans les chiffres que vous avez indiqué
c'est que nous avons la même proportion
de couple htéro et de coupleomau dans le
nombre de mariag que le nombre Pax 93 %
et 7 % et c'est vrai que récemment
encore on m'interrogeait en me disant
mais en 1999 est-ce que vous pensier
qu'il y aurait autant de Pax 25 ans plus
tard j'ai dit bien sûr que non on a
d'abord fait le Pax pour reconnaître le
couple homosexuel pour lui permettre
évidemment de pouvoir s'unir et et donc
à partir de là en 99 vous m'auriez
interrogé j'aurais dit oh il y aura
quelques milliers de Pax par an et là on
a presque autant de Pax que de mariage
et je trouve que ça rend très optimiste
sur la capacité de la société d'abord à
demander à ce que la législation
augmente
à ce que la législation évidemment bouge
et puis après à intégrer les droits
nouveaux à se les approprier et je
trouve que c'est très enthousiasm parce
que ça montre que nous gardons
collectivement en France une grande
capacité d'intégration alors cette
histoire ce long combat qu'on a vécu
avec ce film fait finalement sauter deux
verrous he si je schématise un peu le
Pax 1999 c'est le c'est le couple
l'arrivée des couples de même sexe et
puis 2013 le mariage pour tous là cette
fois c'est l'homoparentalité hein qui
fait son entrée en scène en France ça
sont deux avancées majeures du fait de
ces lois ce sont de deux étapes
effectivement en 1999 on reconnaît le
couple du même sexe c'est qu'on change
dans le Code civil les définitions du
couple qui jusque-l ne pouvait être
constitué que d'une femme et d'un homme
et on dit désormais dans le Code civil
que le couple peut être constitué de
deux personnes de même sexe ou de deux
personnes de sexes différents donc on
légifère sur le couple on reconnaît le
couple on crée un cadre juridique qui
s'appelle le Pax et dans l'étape
suivante à travers l'ouverture du
mariage à tous les couples on pose la
question de l'homoparentalité et de
l'affiliation c'est le deuxième verrou
qui saute parce que le mariage ouvrant à
la ouvrant le droit à l'adoption on
nallait pas évidemment ouvrir le mariage
au couple homosexuel en les privant d'un
droit à l'adoption puisque si étaé faire
tomber une discrimination pour en créer
une autre donc on a ouvert au couple
homosexuel à la fois le mariage donc
l'adoption donc du coup on offre la
possibilité via l'adoption de créer
évidemment des familles homoparentales
et évidemment ultérieurement ce sera
l'ouverture de la PMA le film revient
sur cette période du PACT ça nous étonne
quand même de revoir ces de revoir ces
manifest ation cette hostilité cette
homophobie totalement décomplexée hein
le film rappelle que on a entendu des
mots d'ordes comme les péd au bûcher
donc il y a vraiment pour à mon avis
dans ces débats sur le Pax il y a
vraiment deux questions toujours il y a
une question qui est quel est le rapport
de notre société à l'homosexualité
est-ce que on continue à considérer oui
ou non que l'homosexualité c'est une
orientation sexuelle pathologique ce qui
a été longtemps le cas officiellement
hein donc il y avait un débat pour la
reconnaissance de cette orientation
sexuelle comme une orientation sexuelle
parfaitement ordinaire normale ça
c'était un premier un première première
dimension et la deuxème ça concernait
euh bah ce qu'on appelle un couple tout
simplement c'est vrai que pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a ce ce succès du Pax si on
se souvient il y avait quand même
beaucoup de d'incertitude au départ le
Pax c'est une voix tout à fait française
qui s'est distingué de celle de très
nombreux pays européens qui ont accordé
des droits mais autrement c'est-à-dire
en faisant des des contrats de
partenariat spécifiques pour les
homosexuels et Patrick Bloch Jean-Pierre
Michel d'autres se sont battus pour
qu'on ait une une formule chez nous
universelle qui ne soit pas spécifique
aux homosexuels mais alors la question
c'était mais c'est quoi cette cette
nouvelle chose est-ce que c'est un un
mariage un
sous-mariage voilà et c'était logique et
ce débat moi comme sociologue du droit
j'y ai participé et cetera et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire maintenant d'où vient ce
succès du Pax moi il me semble que ce
succès du Pax vient du fait que avec le
temps ce qu'on aperçoit finalement c'est
que le Pax c'est une forme
d'officialisation de l'union libre c'est
ça me paraître étrange officialisation
du
concubinage au départ hein c'était ça la
question est-ce que les concubins ont
des droits pourquoi le compagnon de
d'une personne malade du sida peut être
chassé de l'appartement c'était ça les
questions et donc c'est vrai que
maintenant on a en quelque sorte grâce
au Pax non seulement un couple de même
sexe Patrick blochche l'a dit c'est très
important on change pour la première
fois la définition du couple après des
siècles et des siècles des millénair où
c'était toujours un homme et une femme
mais en plus on a une réponse pour tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas se marier parce
que maintenant tout le monde peut se
marier qui veulent rester en quelque
sorte en dehors d'une union officielle
et qui auront des droits des droits
sociaux des droits des des droits
fiscaux et cetera cette reconnaissance
évoquée à l'instant des homosexuels à
travers notamment le pax
euh de l'homoparentalité par la suite
est-ce que d'une certaine manière elle
vous a aidé dans votre parcours
personnel j'ai vu que vous aviez fait
votre caming out à à 18 ans euh ça a été
douloureux et vous en témoignez ça a été
une période pas évidente à passer euh et
puis ensuite vous êtes mis donc en en
couple euh est-ce que le travail
législatif qui a été effectué durant ces
années et vous représentez en quelque
sorte une une autre génération une
nouvelle génération ce plateau vous a
vous a aidé dans votre parcours
personnel est-ce que vous pouvez en
témoigner dans oui c'est mê plus que ça
c'est même plus que ça en réalité euh
moi je suis député euh je je je je je je
suis militante politique donc je
considère que oui l'engagement politique
et la loi doit faire évoluer la société
mais ces lois ont été nécessaires
nécessaire je parle même pas de
visibilité nécessaire même pour
l'acceptation de soi dans son chemin
très personnel et et je parle même pas
de l'accueil des familles il est il peut
il peut être difficile il peut être long
euh mais pour autant mais pour autant
notre société elle ne peut pas se
permettre d'une certaine manière de
garder ces discriminations de fait et
donc l'évolution de la loi permet à
chacun en réalité d'acccepter bien sûr
au mêm droit qui est essentiel et aussi
d'une certaine manière accompagner le
parcours très personnel de chacun et ces
parcours sont longs sont longs parfois
parce
que me souviens on peut avoir des
parents qui ont qui sont inquiets quand
on fait un coming out ils sont inquiets
pour toi moi je je voilà je je comprends
cette inquiétude ils ont peur de la
violence de cette homophobie et ça été
votre cas je crois mais bien sûr mais
parce que mais mais parce que parce que
quand on a un enfant on espère
naturellement pour lui une vie peut-être
plus simple peut-être moins difficile
moins douloureuse et on projette une vie
plus douloureuse ou plus difficile quand
on entend parfois et bien ces moments
qui sont durs mais il faut faut avoir
conscience du fait que une famille
auomotarentale ou même quand quand
soi-même on le dit on le dit la première
fois mais on le dit tout le temps quand
vous avez un enfant Vous vous êtes amené
à le dire à chaque fois
au moment bien sûr de la de la
constitution de l'état civil donc quand
tu vas déclarer mais mais c'est d'une
banalité confondante ce que je vais dire
là mais profondément à chaque étape de
la vie puisque nous on est en plein dans
les bodies les difficultés des nuits des
biberons mais quand tu vas faire ton
inscription à la crèche quand tu vas
voir ton médecin quand tu as ton acte et
donc finalement si notre société ne fait
pas évoluer sa propre perception des
modèles familiaux au-delà et donc et enc
relation avec l'évolution de la loi
alors le combat doit continuer et et moi
j'ai la chance d'être de cette
génération qui a bénéficié des combats
que vous avez mené puisque j'ai 34 ans
aujourd'hui et et parce que notre notre
fille Jeanne est née d'une évolution
grâce à cette évolution du droit et
parce qu'on a pu aller simplement dans
une mairie et avoir un acte de naissance
avec cette double filiation quelques
jours après sa naissance parce qu'on a
vu un accompagnement médical d'une
richesse folle mais la société elle-même
n'est pas encore en réalité dans cette
maturité là et c'est là où a ch votre
fille
votre Jeanne he vous NES cité son son
prénom est né en décembre dernier est-ce
qu'avant cela et pour faire couple vous
en êtes passé par la case Pax puis la
case mariage avant d'avoir cet enfant
avec votre compagne Pauline qui
elle-même avait deux enfants d'un
premier mariage écoutez pas du tout
puisque nous avons fait nous nous avons
fait le le choix de cette grande liberté
de dire est-ce qu'on on a la liberté de
se marier ou pas de se paxer ou pas et
finalement puisque l'évolution de
l'affiliation avait été faite peut-être
que ça arrivera dans des années mais
nous n'étions pas dans cette obligation
là enfin je sais pas si mon expression
est claire mais la profonde liberté de
se dire j'ai les mêmes droits donc
finalement j'aurais la possibilité de me
marier ou pas si je le souhaite j'ai la
chance de pouvoir me paxer ou pas si je
le souhaite mais je ne suis pas dans
l'obligation pour protéger ni ma
compagne ni notre fille de devoir le
faire et et nous avons pour le moment
fait ni ce choix ni l'autre mais il
arrivera peut-être mais par contre c'est
là où même dans la réflexion et dans le
livre que j'ai que que j'aiécrit il y a
quelques un an maintenant un an et demi
c'est là où j'ai envie de France j'ai
envie de cette liberté j'ai envie de
cette égalité pour pouvoir si un jour je
fais une demande pour la faire pour les
meilleures raisons du monde non pas
simplement pour protéger mais parce que
ce sera notre décision et donc
finalement l'égalité profonde l'égalité
réelle elle est là elle est dans cette
cette capacité de se dire je ne suis pas
obligé de devoir le faire et ça c'est
parce que des combats ont été menés et
ces combats ils ont commencé avant ma
naissance presque et aujourd'hui on est
la génération qui peut se dire oui on a
cette opportunité là mais faut pas se
leurer je pense qu'il ne faut pas non
plus rendre notre société très idylique
de la discrimination homophobe il y en a
il y en a encore beaucoup les évolutions
sont lentes elle est belle notre société
mais il y a encore du chemin et ce
chemin il est réel on va parler des des
familles euh euh homoparental dont vous
faites partie maintenant euh en écoutant
Caroline mecari qui elle-même a témoigné
dans le film que nous venons de voir on
réécoute ce qu'elle a dit et on en parle
juste après et maintenant on a 40 ans de
recul sur les familles homoparentales
c'est-à-dire 40 ans d'études
sociologiques d'études psychologiques en
France aux États-Unis en Grande-Bretagne
et qu'est-ce que ça montre ça montre que
la la sexualité des parents n'est une
garantie de rien combien d'enfants qui
sont nés dans des familles
hétérosexuelles aujourd'hui sont placés
en France combien d'enfants sont
victimes des violences intraconjugales
dans des familles hétérosexuelles donc
voilà la sexualité des parents n'est une
garantie de rien la sexualité des
lesbiennes ou des gay n'est en rien une
contradication au fait de pouvoir élever
des enfants et ceci vont aussi bien
ils sont comme les autres voilà ce que
nous dit donc Caroline mecari on a 30 40
ans de recul aujourd'hui sur les
familles homoparentales alors ça c'est
sont des propos qui sont qui peuvent
équer des réactions y compris parmi
certaines de ses collègues tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord sur ce recul dont
nous bénéficions aujourd'hui concernant
l'homoarentalité et la situation des
enfants parce que cette situation des
enfants finalement n'a pas fait partie
de tous les débats en tout cas été un
peu à la marge de ce débat c'est un peu
le sentiment que ça nous ça peut aussi
donner est-ce que au moment où il a
s'agit de évidemment de porter le Pax
mais plus encore vous en tant que député
de de de voter le mariage pour tous vous
aviez en tête euh quelque part ce que
serait la situation des enfants et les
questions qui seraient posées autour de
cette question de la famille de la
nouvelle donne dans la famille et dans
cette famille de la situation des des
des des enfants dans ces familles
homoparentales bien sûr d'abord parce
que l'homoparentalité n'est pas née soit
de l'ouverture de l'adoption au couple
homosexuel à travers l'ouverture de
mariage ou à force ie il y a il y a 2
ans avec l'ouverture de la PMA l'omop
parentalité est une situation de fête
c'estàd que nous étions amené à
connaître et rine Terry pourrait en
parler aussi bien que moi des familles
homoparental de fait donc à partir de là
quand comme on dit souvent que c'est
l'arrivée de l'enfant des enfants qui
font famille donc ce qu'il fallait
évidemment c'est placer c'est avant tout
et en avant l'intérêt de l'enfant qui
est au cœur de la convention
internationale d'ailleurs sur les droits
de l'enfant que la France a signé en
1989 et l'intérêt de l'enfant et bien
c'est de pouvoir être éduqué élevé dans
une famille stable si possible aimante
bien entendu qui assure son bien-être sa
sécurité sa bonne éducation et donc à
partir de là il fallait que le droit
évolue pour que d'abord on reconnaisse
le couple et c'était le cas à travers le
Pax et ultérieurement évidemment à
travers le mariage et les PMA qu'on
donne un statut si j'ose dire à ces
famille h mot au mot parental là vous
avez dû faire face à une forte
opposition notamment du côté de la
médecine j'ai retrouvé 4 ans avant la le
vote de du texte concernant le mariage
par les personnes de même sexe et
l'adoption euh cette déclaration de
l'Académie de médecine qui disait
l'ouverture de l'accès à la PMA aux
lesbiennes et aux femmes célibataires
constitue je cite une rupture
anthropologique majeure qui n'est pas
sans risque pour le développement
psychologique et l'épatouissement de
l'enfant voilà ce que disait l'Académie
de meine à l'époque alors sur ce point
je veux bien intervenir parce que j'ai
j'ai été si peux dire aux premières
loges dans dans dans ce débat en fait il
a été virulent déb en fait comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure à chaque moment il y
a il y a deux choses il y a l'attitude
de la société par rapport à une minorité
euh comment considère-t-on les couples
de même sexe est-ce qu'on intègre cette
orientation sexuelle comme une
orientation ordinaire mais il y a aussi
autre chose c'est que quand une minorité
réclame des droits elle nous dit quelque
chose du de la norme elle nous dit
quelque chose de la majorité et souvent
c'est ça qu'on que les gens ne veulent
pas voir alors j'en prends un exemple
très concret au moment des débats sur le
mariage pour tous le l'essentiel du
débat portait déjà sur l'affiliation le
couple s'était passé euh sur
l'affiliation et qu'est-ce qu'on a
entendu dans les manifestations des gens
qui hurlaient on ne pas aux
enfants comme si les couples de même
sexe en partic les couples de femmes
avaient l'intention de faire croire aux
enfant que ils étaient nés de leur lit
si je peux dire donc c'est quand même
extraordinaire jamais les lesbienes
n'ont eu l'intention de faire croire à
leurs enfants qu'ell n'avaient pas
recouru à un don à un don de sperme
elles n elles n'ont aucune ces couples
ne mente jamais alors donc on accusait
de mentir des couples qui n'avaient pas
l'intention de mentir et ce qu'on ne
disait pas et c'est ça qui est très
important c'est que sur la PMA on vivait
sur un modèle mensonger on vivait sur un
modèle depuis les années 90 et même
avant depuis les années 70 dans lequel
on organisait le recours à des dons de
spermme ou à des dons de ou à des dons
d' vocite enfin à des dons à des dons de
gamè tout en le dissimulant tout en
faisant passer donc c'était par
hypothèse des couples hétérosexuels en
âge de procréé en les faisant passer
pour les deux géniteurs de de l'enfant
et donc les couples qu'on avait incités
à mentir c'était les couples
hétérosexuels donc euh il y avait
vraiment une situation hallucinante où
on accusait de mentir ceux qui ne
mentent pas sans vouloir voir que il
révélait en fait que ces couples
homosexuels révélit le pot au rose on va
dire qui était quoi on ne peut plus
continuer avec un modèle ni vu ni connu
en matière de PMA il faut admettre et
c'est ça que pour moi l'immense progrès
que les couples de même sexe ont
apportés à la société toute entière hein
c'est pas seulementavoir les mêmes
droits c'est de nous dire au fond il y a
une nouvelle façon de mettre des enfant
au monde qui n'existait pas avant c'est
l'engendrement avec un tiers d'honneur
un couple qui veut mettre au monde un
enfant donc c'est différent de
l'adoption mettre au monde un enfant ne
peut pas le faire par ses seules forces
procréatives et une tierce personne
donne de sa capacité pour permettre à ce
couple d'avoir un enfant un engendrement
avec tiers d'honneur c'est une nouvelle
façon de mettre des enfants au monde et
grâce à vous je le dis grâce au coupes
de même sexe maintenant la société toute
entière commence à admettre qu'il y a
donc trois façons d'être parents procréé
on va dire à l'ancienne avec ou sans
d'ailleurs l'aide de la médecine adopté
et engendré avec un tiers d'honneur et
c'est ça la nouveauté et c'estes trois
ces trois façons d'établir un lien de
filiation ensuite vont créer le même
lien pour tous mais ça c'est nouveau et
c'est un progrès en vérité et le respect
de l'enfant et de l'histoire de l'enfant
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
on va juste entendre un deuxième
témoignage mais vous allez vous dire
connaître puisqu'il s'agit d'un d'un
couple de femme qui qui vient d'avoir un
enfant mais il y a eu des doutes et des
questionnements de leur part avant
d'avoir cet enfant regardez on est des
parents là aujourd'hui mais avant de
devenir parents je pense qu'on on a le
record du monde de toutes les questions
qu'on a pu se poser avant ah oui ça je
pense il y a plein de couples on va dire
hterau mais de couples qu'on connaît qui
qui se posent même pas mais le cè des
questions qu'on s'est posé il y a une
pression de la société he qui fait qu'on
se pose des questions puis nous-même on
n'est pas dans cette idée d'un enfant à
tout prix on avait envie d'enfant mais
on voulait aussi qu'ils soient heureux
qu'on les mette pas dans une situation
difficile c'était vraiment toute une
période où on on s'est questionné comme
pas possible on a fait plein de
recherches pense qu'on était plus pointu
que n'importe qui sur T c toutes ces
questions là c'est clair avant de
devenir parent je pense qu'on a le
record du monde de toutes les questions
qu'on a pu se poser avant vous étiez
dans le même cas de figure avec votre
compagne avant d'avoir votre enfant sûr
bien sûr parce que parce que la violence
des débats laisser imaginer que c'était
une envie un caprice quelque chose de
soudain et d'un coup on avait envie de
la souvir mais pas du tout la
parentalité c'est un chemin et en fait
la réalité c'est que quand tu as besoin
d'une PMA quand tu as besoin d'un
accompagnement médical que ce soit
d'ailleurs dans des couples hétérosex ou
dans des couples homo homosexuels ou
encore même quand on est
seul la difficulté la la dureté du
traitement de l'accompagnement médical
tamène à faire ce cheminement et presque
tu as moins le droit à la défaillance
dans l'éducation de ton enfant puisque
finalement tout le monde regarde et et
comme une hisor de suspicion de est-ce
que ce sera différent est-ce
que aussi imposé en quelque sorte hein
vous avez dû en couple aller voir un
psychologue ensuite vous êtes all chez
le notaire pour les problèmes de de
filiation avant l'arrivée de votre
enfant il y a tout un parcoursin et
aussi euh mais c'est un chemin c'est un
chemin c'est un chemin où tu tu tu
deviens parent et il est long il est
long et en même temps très sincèrement à
chaque étape tu te poses des questions
et puis après il y a les joies et les
peines de toutes les les de toutes les
PMA et de toutes les Fives avec parfois
ça marche parfois ça ne marche pas
parfois parfois c'est difficile il y a
un traitement médical en tous ceux qui
imaginent que c'est d'un claquement de
doit et que c'est très capricieux pas du
tout et puis même à l'arrivée finalement
de de de l'enfant ou du bébé euh il y a
tout un accompagnement aussi puisque de
fait tu te poses la banalité de toutes
les de toutes les familles lesé
cololique les difficultés les crèches et
c'est là où il y a des familles et moi
il y a quelque chose qui me touche
beaucoup mais dans le combat qui a été
celui du Pax et aujourd'hui les
évolutions nécessaires euh encore dans
notre société c'est qu'il y a quelque
chose de très universel dans les deux
cas il y a la banalité confondante d'une
famille et en même temps il y a quelque
chose de très universel parce que cet
accès il est accès c'est un accès plus
ouvert comme le Pax l'a été et
finalement cette universalité c'est ça
la promesse républicaine et je reviens à
votre personnel pardonnez-moi mais votre
compagne avait eu deux enfants hein d'
d'une première union vous êtes donc dans
le cadre d'une famille à recomposer vous
diriez des choses comme ça aujourd'hui
comment vous attendez cette cette
nouvelle é puisque elle est elle est
consolidée donc elle est recomposée je
suis moi-même l'enfant d'un couple qui a
divorcé qui s lui-même recomposé et
finalement peut-être que nos familles
c'est la mise en lumière de la
multiplicité des formes de famille mais
aujourd'hui quand vous avez même quand
vous êtes un couple hétérosexuel et que
rentre dans votre vie un enfant et et
que vous l'aimez et que vous
l'accompagnez et que vous avez
finalement ce rôle parental dans sa
propre dans cette forme de famille là il
y a encore des rôles qui ne sont pas
reconnus dans notre société vous pouvez
pas aller le chercher à l'école sans
l'autorisation parentale vous vous vous
êtes inquiet quand il est malade et
finalement c'est cette multiplicité de
famill qu'on a peut-être mis en lumière
d'une certaine manière et donc ce combat
pour l'égalité des droits ce combatl est
nécessaire mais il est salvateur c'est
vrai alors ce qui a été quand même le
grand débat euh dès le dès le débat sur
le mariage et et encore cette fois avec
la PMA c'est les opposants disaient mais
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de nous
dire il y a plus d'hommes il y a plus de
femmes le grand sujet c'était pas
simplement la sexualité c'était la
référence au masculin au féminin est-ce
qu'on est en train de nous dire qu'on
veut plus voir voir que des personnes en
quelque sorte assexué que va devenir
dans votre famille la référence
masculine et cetera alors là il y a en
mettant en avant la symbolique du père
la symbolique de la mère ou alors c'est
vrai que ça ça montre une chose c'est
que les gens raisonnaient sur une
hypothèse de famille qui n'existe pas
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là une
famille complètement isolée mais vos
enfants ont des grands-parents ils ont
peut-être même des grands-père ils on
non ils on on même ils on on même
beaucoup puisqueil se trouve que quand
on a une famille recomposée vous avez en
plus les parents qui sont donc ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il suffit de revenir
à la réalité concrète les enfants ne
vivent pas en autarciie dans leur
famille euh les enfants d'un couple de
femme ont des repères masculins ils ont
des grands-pères les enfants des couples
d'hommes ont des grands-mères donc et on
ne fait pas des voilà et donc ils ont
ils sont parfaitement capables de de de
partager avec tous les enfants les les
les références masculines et féminines
de toute façon la la la société si je se
dire il faut la voir tel qu'elle estou
je veux dire on pourrait évoquer les
familles monoparentales tout à fait et
de la même façon je veux dire par là la
proportion très majoritaire d'enfants
qui naissent hors
mariage traduisent le fait que
finalement nos concitoyens et
concitoyens veulent organiser leur vie
de couple puis leur vie familiale en
ayant la liberté de choix et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je rebondis un
instant sur ce que vous avez dit l'une
et l'autre sur justement cet
universalisme qui commence dès le Pax et
qui évidemment se poursuit ensuite et le
choix que nous avons fait avec
Jean-Pierre Michel alors c'était un
choix c'estz facile parce que au Parti
socialiste originalement nous étions
chevénemti donc des républicains euh
très très convaincus mais on s'est
inscrit dans cette démarche très
universelle et je me souviens puisque
les oppositions étaient très vives lors
du débat sur le Pax lorsque j'ai i
toutes les associations familiales
qu'elles étaient toutes opposé au Pax
sauf les associations laïques je dirais
bien entendu je me souviens qu'à la fin
de l'audition le président des
associations familiales catholiques
vient me voir et me dit Monsieur le
Député on restera évidemment toujours
opposé au Pax mais si vous ne faisiez le
Pax que pour les couples homosexuels
notre opposition serait moins vive parce
que ce qui les gênait dans leur esprit
c'est qu'on mélange les torchons et les
serviettes c'est les couples ou les
coupl mot euh néanmoins les chiffres
nous nous disent aussi que il y a des
difficultés persistantes pour fonder une
famille pour les couples de même sexe
selon l'Association des Parents gay et
lesbiens mais enfin ça recoupe un
certain nombre d'autres études seulement
200 familles au m parental ont réussi à
adopter par exemple al c'est un droit
qui leur a été donné en 2013 autrement
dit il y a maintenant 10 ans bien sûr il
y a encore des difficultés à fond des
familles notamment via l'adoption malgré
ces lois
à l'adoption est déjà difficile pour
tous les couples hein et c'est un un
très très long chemin mais euh c'est
vrai que l'agrément donné au couple pour
pouvoir adopter se fait au niveau des
départements et on doit pointer
inévitablement une inégalité
territoriale qui n'est pas acceptable il
faudrait sans doute revisiter les
conditions qui sont mises pour que les
couples puissent avoir cet agrément à
l'adoption où il y a incontestablement
encore aujourd'hui des discriminations
entre couples homo et couples hétéro
c'est toujours euh euh le souci qu'on
doit avoir de voir comment la loi
s'applique l'évaluer et corriger alors
ça amène à poser un un débat qui est
complexe mais qui est devant nous qui
est celui de la gestation pour autrui il
ne faut pas l'éviter ce débat euh les
couples d'hommes qui essayent d'adopter
euh entrent dans des cheminements très
difficiles et au fond très souvent euh
ils s'aperçoivent que ça ne va ça ça ne
va ça ne va pas aboutir autrement dit
c'est l'adoption oou l'illégalité parce
que la GPA auquelle vous faites
référence peut être pratiquée en dehors
de la France hein c'est cas en Belgique
par exemple mais il y il y a d'autres
pays frontal ce que je veux dire c'est
que pour le moment on a quand même cette
situation où on a permis au couple de
femmes donc d'avoir tous les droits de
tous les couples à et évidemment comme
personne ne dit que donner du sperme ou
donner une gestation c'est la même chose
la gestation pour autruille est
interdite pour tout le monde elle est
pas interdite pour les les homo elle est
interdite pour tout le monde en France
mais il faudrait peut-être qu'on lance
un débat posé euh à partir de la de
l'expérience qui est celle de la GPA à
l'international parce que derrière ce
mot voyez on met des choses tout à fait
opposé on met des des des cas qui sont
vraiment de
l'exploitation de la réfication des
femmes qui sont traité comme l'argument
numéro 1 c'est la commercialisation du
ventre des femmes voilà c'est l'argument
des contre ça situation concrète où les
femmes peuvent être traitées comme des
sortes d'incubateurs vivants personne ne
défend ça mais ce qu'il faut admettre
c'est que au Canada aux États-Unis en
Angleterre en Belgique il existe des il
existe des gestations et dans d'autres
pays des gestations qu'on appelle
éthiques dans lesqueles justement loin
que la femme soit considérée comme un
incubateur vivant ce sont d'abord ses
droits sa dignité qui sont au centre
c'est elle qui a choisi le couple pour
qu'elle va porter l'enfant et cetera et
donc la GPA à vos yeux ça serait la
dernière strate de ce long combat euh
dont nous avons parlé à travers ce film
et et dans cette émission c'està-dire
que c'est comment est-ce que deux hommes
peuvent bénéficier de ce qu'on appelle
la procréation médicalement assistée
sinon par une gestation pour autrui il y
en a doncut tabou donc je pense qu'il
faut il faut mettre le débat là où il
est il y a des gestations pour autrui
magnifique et je peux témoigner j'en
connais beaucoup et il y a des
gestations pour autruit horribles il
faut il faut lancer ce débat et et
sortir du pour ou contre la GPA qui n'a
pas de sens bon je vous laisse le mot de
la fin il nous reste 30 secondes très
sincèrement moi j'adhère totalement au
propos puisque il faut sortir des tabous
et les tabous ça en fait partie
puisqueaujourd'hui il y a ces enfants
ils sont présents et donc comment on les
accompagne aussi c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure cette universalité elle
est nécessaire parce que c'est
l'héritage même de notre modèle de
société en tout cas c'est celui qui est
important pour moi mais si j'ai fait le
choix de parler et de rendre d'une
certaine publi une partie de notre
intimité vous savez moi j'ai grandi dans
une famille qui qui avit l'habitude de
dire vivons cachés vivons heureux c'est
c'est donc du coup c'est une sorte de
manière de se forcer mais je l'ai fait
parce que il y a encore quelques
semaines en île-de-fance donc juste à
quelques pas d'ici il y a encore on a
encore retrouvé une jeune fille dans une
cave qui a été violenté pendant des
semaines parce que elle avait dit à ses
parents qui ont appris qu'elle était
qu'elle était lesbienne parce que cette
homophobie elle existe encore dans notre
société mais elle prend plein de forme
parfois plus sourde parfois plus
violente parfois finalement de rejet si
on a encore tant besoin de de ce combat
si on a besoin encore d'association si
on a besoin de paroles libr et de
témoignage c'est qu'il y a encore des
parents qui ne comprennent pas des
parents qui violentent et certes le
chemin peut être dur le chemin peut être
long mais le droit doit être l'élément
le plus salvateur et le plus protecteur
et donc le droit ne peut pas être
discriminant parce que sinon notre
société et bien n'accompagne pas les
évolutions et donc si on a parlé si on a
rendu ça public c'est aussi pour
permettre peut-être à des parents qui
verront leurs enfants quel que soit leur
origine leur culture sociale peu importe
et bien pouvoir peut-être avoir des
modèles des idées des images des
témoignages et peut-être évoluer et
c'est ce qui nous permettra de lever des
tableaux profonds et peut-être aller
chercher cette égalité ça sera le mot de
la fin vraiment merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à à ce débat les
réactions ça sera sur hashtagdbat dooG
bien entendu merci à Selma s Sarah
udeline qui m'ont aidé à préparer cette
émission et je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débad dooc et ça sera bien entendu avec
son documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt